the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today I'm going to talk about a
fate of Tyrion Lannister in the upcoming
season we've seen a lot of leaked photos
of Peter Dinklage aka Tyrion in a few
different locations we've seen Tyrion
Lannister in Dragonstone ending King's
Landing along with many encounters with
other major characters as we all know
last time I saw Tyrion was in season six
finale in which he had been sailing to
Westeros beside Daenerys her hand of the
Queen and it's her most trusted advisor
few months ago we've seen firstly
forward also Peter Dinklage
along with Emilia Clarke known as
Daenerys Targaryen on the eyelids of
gasps Stalag axe which will depict Ryan
stone in the upcoming season which means
that Daenerys will land a dragon stone
on the east coast of Westeros but only
with her advisers in their own armies as
we can see from leaked photos meaning
the Tyrion will land a dragon stone as
well just like leaked photos confirmed
as they surpass seeing more and more
main characters who are appearing at
Dragonstone
more and more characters who are having
meetings with Tyrion
firstly let's start the leaked photos in
mysterion miss Annie and Conner welcome
Jon Snow and I will see were to
Dragonstone with a scene in which the
king in the north and the hand of the
Queen shared a formal handshake we're
going to see some kind of a union
between Jon and Tyrion who have not seen
each other since Tyrion pissed off the
edge of the wall and left Castle black
after Jon and I arrived a dragon stone
it won't take too long to wait for a
meeting between Jon and Daenerys here's
the proof the image was taken from a
distance but that is without a doubt the
meeting between Daenerys Targaryen and
Jon Snow as a reason of their meeting we
can assume is the nearest who sent an
invitation to ask from Jon to support
her as the rightful claim er of the Iron
Throne while John accepts invitation to
come to Dragonstone to discuss with the
nurse about the true war that is coming
and to try to convince her that real war
is just about to come is the one against
the White Walkers and their whites at
first the nurse one believes Jon
statements about the undead army then
his main goal is to bring her and her
house the Iron Throne which has been
taken from them
but Tyrion will try to come insert the
John wouldn't lie about those things
pointing on the fact that John is
honorable just as his father actually
uncle had been Tyrion Lannister will be
along with Davos the one that is going
to ask or ginjury from King's Landing to
Dragonstone to meet Daenerys this will
be Tyrion first time to set foot in
King's Landing after he killed his
father and escaped with various this
will also be the first out of few times
in which Tyrion will be a king reigning
in the upcoming season Joe Dempsey the
actor that plays ginjury appeared first
time on season 7 filming set on marilla
Beach America we've seen a video in
which Davos and injury were at King's
Landing and together we're preparing the
boat leave when all of a sudden two gold
cloaks approached Davos then in favor to
avoid a conflict demonstrated to them
that the boat is innocently empty by
pulling back the tarp Davos also bribed
the gold cloaks who turned to leave but
just then
Tyrion showed up and passed by them the
gold cloaks paula Tyrion and came back
immediately
perhaps they recognized the most famous
dwarf in the Seven Kingdoms or they just
suspected that it might be Tyrion
Lannister that was try to avoid a
possible conflict by trying to talk to
them but the gold clothes grab their
swords
that's the moment then ginjury reacted
picked up his Warhammer from the boat
and struck them from behind whereupon
Davos Tyrion and ginjury push the boat
off shore and headed to Dragonstone let
me just tell you that it's not
surprising that ginjury will be at
King's Landing in the first episodes of
season 7 considering the last scene of
ginjury in which Davos saved him from
being burnt alive by sending him to
King's Landing in a rowboat and towing
to keep rolling until he comes to King's
Landing
or major injury at first sad that the
gold books are looking for him
pointing that he wouldn't be safer there
but I was convinced him that he's going
to be just fine since the gold clothes
don't know how he looks like yesterday
isn't filming sattell passing more and
more main characters arriving to
Dragonstone more and more characters
were encountering with Tyrion Lannister
while the crew was filming Zumaya
George has been seen while talking to
Tyrion as then
nurse approached escorted by the
TriCaster guard and have had a
conversation with Jorah there in also
telling in the leaked scene which ended
surprisingly as John Davos injury and
Jorah with the boat and went away
together on their mission to catch white
if able to prove the whole Westeros that
the real war is just about to come
there's also interesting sentence in
liquid which says the Tyrion will
dissuade the nearest from attacking
King's Landing directly with dragons in
fear that it would endanger a lot of
innocent lives I don't know if this is
going to come true but I can definitely
stage happening since that's something
that Tyrion will advise Daenerys to do
or not to do now here we come to the
scenes from the italica set which are
definitely going to be used in season
seven finale since Jeremy Podesta the
guy who is directing a season 7 premiere
and finale was in Italica himself those
scenes will include Tyrion as well this
is even more exciting once you realize
that 13 starring cast members are
confirmed to have a role as dragon pet
accompanied by four guest stars with 17
major characters the scenes filmed in
dragon pit will be the most important
scenes in season 7 for future events
this will be a historic confluence of
characters Cersei Daenerys Jon Snow
Jaime Davos and Sandy sander Theon
Brienne Very's bran Jorah urine Qyburn
pod Gregor and Tyrion with all these
characters being together same place
anything is possible to happen the
reason of all these characters being
together the same place is two reasons
the true danger the danger of the undead
army and to unite all of their armies in
favor to stand a chance against the
White Walkers and their rights that's
the reason that lie Daenerys and John
supported by Tyrion to invite all these
characters to dragon pit and to bring
the white over there which Dany and John
together somehow are going to capture
I've already explained the whole white
hunt mission my previous videos so feel
free to check it out for more details
I'm not sure how exactly they are going
to be able to pass the war with a white
but I have a few theories first and the
most possible theory would be that at
the time
randal already past the wall which would
allow John and his team to pass the
world with the captured white as well
since brain is marked in case your brain
would decide to sacrifice himself in
favor to protect the rest of the realm
which I highly doubt he's going to
there's also possibility of John and his
team passing through the wall along with
the white I know that you're a little
bit confused right now since white
walkers and whites can't pass the wall
because of the strong magic in it but
let me explain back in the first season
do remember when John Banville found
wanted brother of the Nights Watch with
John with few other sworn brothers
brought to the Castle black meaning that
they pass the wall with that's dead body
do you remember that while they were
passing the wall with him the dead man
was still human but later that night he
became a white well by my theory the
nursing Journal says the wall with one
of the dead teammate who is going to die
while helping John in his mission to
capture white which is by the way
confirmed by leaked blood and leaked
photos meaning that one member of John's
team who is going to die will be only
that human at a time which would allow
John to passage into the wall but later
that that man would become a white
beside those two possibilities there is
one more the third and the last
possibility in my opinion could be that
John and Danny won't even pass the wall
with a captured white they don't
necessarily have to pass the wall to
bring a white dragon pet they could
bring a captured white in the boat by
the sea the best example for this third
possibility is Stannis Baratheon who
came in his army beyond the wall in the
feed and mance rayder without investing
the wall also the important thing about
is is that the italic Assad has dragon
paste along with 17 major characters is
going to have a big role in season 7 and
the outcome of that meeting which is
going to be organized by Daenerys he is
going to have a great importance for the
events to come in season 8 considering
that the most probable this scene is
going to be released in season 7 finale
meanwhile according to leaked plot
theory and the Davos will signal they
meet with Jaime and Bronn as king of
landing meaning in which Tyrion is going
to try to convince his brother Jaime to
join him
to join the we can call it good side my
dream is going to refuse where the
statement that he is the Lannister and
that he would never betray his house
well that's Jamie's opinion before
knowing search his opinion about the
undead army before knowing that inserts
his opinion Dwight Walker someone with
their white horde are going to defeat
all of her enemies which would only
benefit her that's also Jamie's opinion
before realizing sources say intentions
of having her army out of the Great War
after she is apparently going to promise
Daenerys that she will send her army to
the north to support the living side as
a result of all of that supported by
Cersei Hammack her new husband yearn
Jaime will decide to save the world
Jaime will kill once again the one
cooking was supposed to protect with his
own life but also Jaime will once again
save a lot of innocent lives
Jaime is going to kill Thursday at the
end of season seven I explained this the
gold wedding tear in my previous video
named new red wedding so feel free to
check it out for more details in
conclusion Tyrion will continue being
Danny's advisor and is going to play a
major role in season 7 as he has been
doing since the very beginning since the
first season we can expect a lot of
encounters between Tyrion and other main
characters and at the end of the
upcoming season lens two brothers Tyrion
Jaime might travel together on their way
north which would represent the real
threat for the undead army I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
piece
[Music]
you